siempre ha habido un flujo de
inmigrantes en la frontera sur que
divide a méxico de guatemala la gran
diferencia ahora es que las personas se
mueven en grupos bastante grandes o sea
en caravanas la mayoría de estas
personas desean solicitar asilo en los
eeuu
sin embargo la política de inmigración
de los eeuu han dejado a estas personas
varadas en mexico la situación es muy
grave por tres razones primero la
política migratoria mexicana y control
de la frontera sur es reactiva en lugar
de proactiva tampoco es estable la
reacción a los migrantes cambia
diariamente dando nuevo gobierno de
andrés lópez obrador prometió adoptar un
enfoque más humano para los migrantes
que pasan por méxico en enero los
miembros de la caravana que en su
mayoría eran de honduras recibieran
visas humanitarias que les permiten
quedarse
en mexico por un año pero más
recientemente méxico ha estado
deteniendo y deportando a los migrantes
según los datos que tengo mexico de 445
mil 370 personas entre diciembre y abril
segundo ahora méxico es un país de
destino
el sistema de determinación de
refugiados de méxico está sobrecargado y
con fondos insuficientes no puede
manejar tantos casos y tercero la
emigración de los centroamericanos es
fenómeno migratorio mixto es decir los
migrantes tienen necesidades de
protección internacional pero también
buscan mejorar su situación económica es
poco probable que los reconozca como
refugiados en méxico en los estados
unidos y en canadá
pero por razones muy a menudo no pueden
regresar a su país de ciudadanía en fin
es una situación bastante complicada
[Música]